but here's what i want to talk about why
does yeet and other rappers white
rappers too not just ye but
in this video specifically yeet
why does he not say [ __ ] in his and his
rap songs um
a lot
of like if you listen to black rap music
every black rapper says it right
so it's kind of a rap music thing
but then you get these white rappers
that come in
and they avoid saying it in their music
post malone has said it you can go
google the video
there was a uh old snapchat video of
post malone and he goes yeah we watched
too cute
cause i'm gonna give you guys the honest
raw
truth here
when i was growing up in my neighborhood
where i'm from in jacksonville florida
all my white friends said here every
freaking one of them
what's up [ __ ] how you doing today bro
you know what i'm saying like that
that's just how you talk that's how you
talk
and it is what it is
uh 69 he's not black he says it all the
time
um
fat joe he says it and people get mad at
him for saying it but he still says it
so here's my question it's like and i'm
not saying yeet specifically but are are
most white rappers scared to say it
because they don't want to face backlash
if they do i say if you want to say it
say it it's [ __ ] it's nothing it means
nothing it's [ __ ] it's just a word who
gives a [ __ ]
i mean
if if you say it
um and you have a black friend and he
gets upset about it then you guys can
have a discussion and you can just tell
them look i just say it it doesn't mean
anything racist to me personally so i'm
just saying it because i don't care it's
just a word to me
don't follow this dude's advice
that's not how the world works
that's do not do it
don't don't do it
don't don't don't don't do it
you're gonna get snuff hey whatever
don't don't don't don't do it
but um i remember stitches had a song
called uh the name of the song was
called [ __ ]
and uh i've seen way too many [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's such a
he says it's just a word but this man
just seems like he's so excited to say
this crazy he can't wait to see it yeah
yeah
it's just a word he wants to say it it's
such a fire song look it up there's a
video for it
and there's a line there where he goes
uh
they told me stop saying [ __ ] you is a
dumb [ __ ]
at this point he's fine he's looking for
reasons to say it
at this point why don't rap rappers say
nick
well let me say this many times just to
compensate for all the times they didn't
say
like basically saying like how the media
is like why is this white guy saying
and he's like [ __ ] you i'm gonna say you
know what i mean so um
like i said if he doesn't want to say it
then i totally respect that uh i got no
issue with that i i said in my youtube
video i said that
um black people don't listen to you and
what i meant was hood street guys
and a lot of people got upset about that
um but here's my question if he did say
do you think the hood would [ __ ] with
him more because they're like oh he
relates to us he talks like us i feel
like
you're disconnected my dude
oh my god my guy
no
the hood wouldn't [ __ ] with him more
they would [ __ ] him up but not [ __ ] with
him more you really grew up in the safe
part of jacksonville ford yes that's
what i'm realizing right now when you
said ah me and my white friends yes you
guys always said it around you and your
wife yeah that's very obvious to me
because the lack of self-worth is here
is pretty funny to watch because i feel
like when white rappers avoid saying it
that's
why a lot of black people can't really
like relate to the music no no no it's
not it's it's not the worst it's not
because eminem didn't say the word that
i couldn't relate to his music it's
because his music wasn't for
listen why folks love eminem all right
listen listen love him and i don't even
met him i'm not even thinking he's
battering like that it's not that [ __ ]
there's some black folks some hey but if
you go to his concerts the overwhelming
sea of people there quite and i ain't
never been no party
never been no party in the hood and they
played eminem my whole life true
never been to homies car true and they
played them in that nothing against it
no but it's not because you didn't say
the n-word it's just like just don't
rock with the music it's cool no i
haven't did it would do with the word
that's what i'm trying to say he's
trying to say the reason why
uh folks
is because of their work
like if they heard like and you were
just talking normal i think more hood
dudes would talk would would mess with
it and then white guys would too because
they're saying to the boys when i was in
college all the white dudes are saying
it to each other on the nerdy way i
guess what's up my uh you know like
nobody gave up nobody gave a [ __ ] and i
don't see any white youtubers saying it
like boba lamb you know shout out to bob
lamb i never heard him say it does he
say in his personal life you'd have to
ask him that i'd be
willing to bet that he does or around
certain people a lot of white people
don't why is he getting so excited about
what people might be saying privately
that's the weird part to me yeah he
seems like we're like hey hey hey you do
it
what he too it feels like he's like
like he's saying get behind close to
come on say it with me
do you like
do you think he's like do you think he's
serious
i think he's 100 this is someone who
likes self-worth 100 you don't think
he's like this is not a bit trolling
you're not a bit that's not a bit it's
not a big it doesn't look like but
okay
i think you forget about the caucasity
get something that that's that's that's
that's that is very much called cassidy
all right let's let's talk about this we
already talked we already spoke about
this if everyone's being honest about
the word the rules surrounding the word
make no sense that's one
and two
i don't even get why you want to say the
word so badly that's the thing
huh it isn't that deep
but why did you want to say that deep
you know what i was thinking why does he
want to be why
you know like if i was with a white girl
and she was trying to say like i look at
her point like why do you care so much
you'll be like
i'm not going to start beating her is
that no
i'm gonna think she's cringy just walk
away from me yeah
right but
i don't get why people care so badly
just keep it pushing you know what i'm
saying
like when i go to certain countries
right i know there's certain things i
can't say
there are certain things you can't say
in certain places fair either for
political reasons for whatever reasons
and i don't think it's that deep so long
as this doesn't finish completely on
your right to free speech and your
ability to express yourself like having
one or two words that excluded that's
okay
that's okay
just keep it pushing it's not that deep
that's what i think like
you want to have a philosophical debate
about that sure fine but if people feel
that emotionally charged about it just
keep a push it's like one or two words
you got to exclude from your vocabulary
it's not that deep right with women you
can't use the c word
right
can't do it not north america you can do
it in australia a different context oh
yeah you could do an australia different
context you can do it in uk
okay how you shut up you [ __ ] [ __ ]
to me if you were to ask me like yo i
would justify why ruff i'm gonna keep it
stacked with you the rules don't make
any sense the fact that an asian dude
who grew up in the hood can say it
around that area but if you go to a
different spot it can't say like it
doesn't make any sense right you have
some rappers who are latino who can't
say but do they really identify as black
it's kind of confusing it doesn't make
any sense if we're being honest who gets
a pass and who does it so for me
personally i'm just like whatever you
don't want nobody's like you name fat
joe yeah it's like fat joe is black
but j.lo isn't
you know what i mean yeah it doesn't
make sense and to me to me i said that
already yeah fat joe is black yes
but jlo ain't yes and if i see fat joe
saying it i'm gonna be like um but if i
see jlo singing i'm like
you know what i mean yeah so it's just
one of those things where
why do you care so much and i find it
kind of sus when i hear white dudes like
desperately want to say to me it just
feels like you were told no for
something and you wanted yes immediately
like you just can't handle that
you get what i'm saying who cares just
keep it pushing mm-hmm and trust me his
advice was terrible do not go to black
folks don't say that don't go to the
hood and start writing and saying that
you will get stumped even even even i'm
not even thinking it's okay i'm just
saying that's what's gonna happen that's
what's going to happen straight up even
with your friends your friend might
stump you don't do it and if you don't
understand why if you've never lived in
the states right like i've lived there
for some time you have to understand
race
and race related issues go very very
deep there are generational wounds for a
lot of folks not for everybody but for a
lot of folks yeah that word is often
times like the flagpole you get me it's
the flagship for that stuff it is the
beacon you say that everybody's head
turn so just be mindful that when you
think of like why is it such a thing
like it goes deep and if you're not
ready unpack all that don't even bother
going into it
um so my personal take is start water
random people insane anger yeah don't
worry
this guy's fortunate he's not hanging
around black folks because i know he
doesn't say like that there's no way he
would have been snuff he would have been
slapped by somebody because i know even
if i was okay with it a hypothetical
word i can't walk with you anywhere no
no because you're wild yeah you're wild
yeah it's like walking with a girl who
just screams and yells at people and
threatens them i can't take you anywhere
no not that i wouldn't want to be around
you but i couldn't now because you will
get me in trouble now you say it you're
getting snuff and i'm getting stuff
because yeah because i'm i'm co-signing
i'm never what how do i feel me i don't
say it to me i don't know why i do say
it one time what are you saying
it was just like how it's like i'm
comfortable i was like do i look like i
know you like that yeah because my my
white homies know it's not sick yeah
right and it's cool they're not mad but
they're not oh i just really like i why
do you care so much just keep it pushing
it's weird
i gotta look at you funny yeah i
most definitely i'm gonna be like you're
weird yeah you got issues and there's
and there's words like that out there
and i just be like cool if you don't
want me saying that like whatever keep
it pushing it's not that deep
i don't get it i don't get it you go to
the hood you start going up to our team
hey what a vato they're like
white dude they don't look at you stupid
they're gonna look at me [ __ ] you jay
wait what are you doing hey what up
get on the homes they're gonna think
they're gonna think i'm making but
anyways this is my thoughts on anything
else you want to add
all right let's know what you guys